[Music]
in tonight's democracy 20/20 report new
Fox polls indicate Joe Biden leads
President Trump in three major
battleground states Wisconsin registered
voters prefer the Democrat by 9
percentage points the margin is four in
Arizona two in Ohio
also tonight Republicans are now seeking
a new home for this summer's nominating
convention for real not just talking
about it
here's correspondent Peter Doocy in all
three swing states were buying leads
Trump Arizona Ohio and Wisconsin voters
in a Fox News poll have something in
common the exact same percentage of
people in each place 65 percent think
it's important for president Trump to
set an example and wear a mask in public
and in all three states Biden leads with
voters who say they are extremely
motivated to vote in the election this
comes as another swing state North
Carolina
is losing a convention president drum
tweets governor Cooper is still in
shelter-in-place mode and not allowing
us to occupy the arena as originally
anticipated and promised would have
showcased beautiful North Carolina to
the world and brought in hundreds of
millions of dollars and jobs for the
state because of NC Governor we are now
forced to seek another state to host the
2020 Republican National Convention some
being considered Florida Georgia
Tennessee and Nevada one of them gets
the high-profile events like the
president accepting the nomination
Charlotte just keeps the conventions
official business meetings and
Republicans there say that's devastating
especially for those folks that are
employed in the hospitality industry who
have been shut down and shut out of work
a DNC spokeswoman calls this a
distraction saying about Trump quote he
has abandoned the people of North
Carolina while refusing to acknowledge
the severity of this pandemic Joe Biden
is trying to lead the way on reforming
police tactics like where to shoot a
suspect
standing there and teaching the cop as
an unarmed person coming at him with a
knife or something to shoot him in the
leg he's dead it in the heart it's a
very different thing but Republicans
call that irresponsible next thing you
know somebody will suggest well just
just shoot the weapon out of their hand
that only happens in the movies one of
the group's up for grabs in the new Fox
polls out tonight suburban white voters
in Arizona they like Trump in Wisconsin
they like Biden in Ohio they're split
but a lot can change between now and the
election five months from today Brett
Peter Doocy thank you